esta vez tenemos la función de x igual a
x cuadrada por el logaritmo natural de x
y lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
ver si podemos encontrar los valores
extremos para gdx entonces hay valores
de x donde gm toma un valor máximo
absoluto o un valor mínimo absoluto
algunas veces puede llamarlos máximo
global o mínimo global ahora lo primero
que quiero hacer es pensar en cuál es el
dominio para esta función g
cuál es el dominio dónde está definida
esta función y sabemos que bueno esto
está definido para todos los números
reales pero el logaritmo natural de x
está definido solamente para valores
positivos entonces el argumento me tiene
que ser un valor positivo así que lo
puedo escribir aquí mi dominio van a ser
todas las x que sean mayor que 0 todos
los números reales
mayores que 0 y esto porque si x fuera 0
esto de aquí no estaría definido no hay
ninguna potencia a la que puedas elevar
para obtener 0 y el logaritmo natural de
un número negativo no está definido
entonces este es nuestro dominio así que
nuestros valores extremos deben de estar
dentro de este dominio ahora veamos si
podemos encontrar algunos extremos
locales y ver si algunos de ellos son
buenos candidatos para los extremos
absolutos entonces podemos encontrar
extremos locales buscando los valores
críticos así que vamos a sacar la
derivada de esta función la derivada de
esta función g prima de x va a ser igual
y bueno para derivar esta función hay
que usar la regla del producto entonces
la derivada de x cuadrada es 2x la
derivada del primero por el segundo como
esta
2x por el logaritmo natural de x
y a esto le sumamos el primero tal cual
está que es x cuadrado por la derivada
del segundo la derivada del logaritmo
natural de x es 1 / x
entonces me queda 1 /
ahora bien podemos reducir esto un poco
porque x cuadrada por 1 / x eso es lo
mismo que x siempre y cuando nos estemos
tomando las x mayores que 0 así que
hasta aquí vamos bien esta es mi
derivada la derivada que estaba buscando
y con esta derivada voy a buscar los
puntos críticos los puntos críticos son
los puntos en el dominio es decir las x
que son más grandes que 0 tales que que
prima de x sea indefinida o sea igual a
cero así que qué te parece si primero
pensamos en qué puntos que prima de x es
igual a cero eso quiere decir que me voy
a tomar 2x
por el logaritmo natural de x ok
a esto le voy a sumar x y esto todo esto
lo voy a hacer igual a 0 y veamos que
puedo hacer aquí puedo restar x de ambos
lados y me quedaría que todos x por el
logaritmo natural de x
esto sería igual a menos x y ahora bueno
ahora se me ocurre que puedo dividir
todo entre 2 x y podemos hacer eso
porque sabemos que x es más grande que 0
entonces no puede ser cero si dividimos
todo entre 2x me queda que el logaritmo
natural de x es igual a bueno es igual a
menos un medio porque si / menos x entre
2 x las x se cancelan y me queda
simplemente menos un medio ahora tengo
el logaritmo natural de x es igual a
menos un medio o dicho de otra manera si
quiero despejar la x
x va a ser igual a efe elevado a la
potencia menos un medio es decir x es
igual a la función exponencial elevada a
la potencia menos un medio
recuerden que el logaritmo natural es
simplemente el logaritmo en base y
entonces esto es exactamente lo mismo
que bueno esto lo podemos escribir como
1 entre la raíz cuadrada de elevado a la
menos un medio es lo mismo que 1 entre
la raíz cuadrada de entonces este es un
punto en el cual nuestra derivada es
igual a 0 es un valor crítico para
nuestra función jefe original y de hecho
este es el único lugar donde la derivada
es igual a cero ahora me también te
tienes que preguntar habrá otros puntos
donde prima esté indefinida bueno
tendría que ser puntos dentro de nuestro
dominio
amos que haría esto indefinido si
observas 2x y x se pueden evaluar para
cualquier x mientras que el logaritmo
natural de x se puede evaluar en su
argumento para valores mayores o iguales
a cero justo lo que teníamos en el
dominio x tiene que ser mayor que es
cero pero es justo
nuestra restricción original así que
cualquier punto dentro de este dominio
va a estar definido muy bien una vez que
ya sabemos eso podemos decir que es
solamente este va a ser mi único valor
crítico así que qué te parece si
dibujamos una recta numérica y vemos qué
es lo que está pasando a los lados de
este punto crítico así que voy a dibujar
por aquí una recta numérica voy a
dibujar esta recta numérica y este es mi
eje x
supongamos que por aquí pongo al cero y
bueno por acá tengo al menos uno por acá
voy a tener al uno por acá voy a tener
al 2 y veamos este valor dónde está
bueno uno entre raíz de esto es cercano
a uno pero menor que él esto va a tomar
un valor como por aquí este toma el
valor de 1 entre la raíz de e
muy bien y bueno nos vamos a pegar
solamente las x mayores que 0 así que
qué te parece si primero pensamos en
este intervalo primero vamos a pensar en
este intervalo si te das cuenta es el
intervalo que va de 0 hasta 1 entre la
raíz de ok
y bueno vamos a pensar donde mi primera
derivada es positiva o negativa y
después tenemos este otro intervalo las
x que son mayores que este valor es
decir mi segundo intervalo va a ser todo
esto que tengo aquí todo esto que tengo
aquí que si observas es de 1 entre la
raíz de hasta infinito déjame notarlo
este intervalo es de 1 entre la raíz de
hasta infinito muy bien ahora vamos a
probar con un valor en este intervalo
para ver cuánto vale su derivada y se me
ocurre tomarme no sé un valor entre este
intervalo aunque te parece si vemos
cuánto vale que prima de 0.1
y bueno esto si lo sustituimos aquí me
va a quedar 2 por 0.1
eso es 0.2 0.2 que multiplica el
logaritmo natural de 0.1 ya esto le
tenemos que sumar 0.1 a esto le sumamos
0.1 ahora este valor de aquí me va a dar
algo negativo esto de aquí me va a dar
algo negativo y de hecho algo más
negativo que menos 1 ya que piense en
esto he elevado a la menos 1 esto es lo
mismo que uno entre
esto es aproximadamente uno entre 2.7 es
aproximadamente 0.3 o 0.4 a un número
entre esto así que para llegar a 0.1
tiene que ser aún más negativo esto
tiene que ser menor que menos 1 esto
tiene que ser menor que menos 1 y si
multiplicamos 0.2 por algo menor que
menos 1 me dan algo menor que menos 0.2
y si a esto le sumamos 0.1 bueno en
definitiva esto de aquí me va a dar algo
negativo es decir que en esta parte mi
primera derivada y esto es lo importante
va a ser menor que es cero
en este intervalo que tenemos aquí y
bueno también pudimos traer la
calculadora por aquí pero evaluarlo me
parece más sencillo ahora veamos qué
pasa en el otro intervalo en el
intervalo que va desde 1 entre la raíz
de hasta infinito vamos a tomarnos un
valor aquí para probar el signo de la
primera derivada y bueno el valor más
sencillo que se me ocurre es tomarme 1
así que cuánto vale que prima de 1 bueno
pues esto va a ser igual a 2 por 1 es 2
por el logaritmo natural de 1 ya esto le
sumamos 1 ahora esto es muy fácil porque
el logaritmo natural de 100 por 2
a todo esto 0 entonces simplemente me
queda 1 lo cual tiene signo positivo eso
quiere decir que aquí la primera
derivada de x es mayor que 0
así que parece que nuestra función está
decreciendo del intervalo 0 hasta 1
entre la raíz de y después de esto en el
intervalo 1 entre la raíz de hasta
infinito
esta función está creciendo eso quiere
decir que estamos pasando de decrecer
tocamos este punto y después empezamos a
crecer lo que quiere decir que nuestra
función está tocando un punto global
mínimo o un punto mínimo absoluto en
este valor de aquí así que déjame
escribirlo vamos a tener un mínimo
absoluto en
x igual a 1 entre la raíz de lujo y no
sólo eso además no hay un máximo
absoluto a medida que vamos después de 1
entre la raíz de m
sabemos que nuestra función sigue
creciendo y creciendo y creciendo para
siempre inclusive lo pueden ver a kim x
cuadrada es una función que crece de
manera indefinida hasta el infinito y el
lugar es natural de x es una función que
también crece pero más lento que x
cuadrada pero todavía irá sin límites
hacia el infinito así que no hay un
punto máximo absoluto déjame notarlo
también sabemos que no hay un máximo
absoluto
qué te parece si ahora vemos la gráfica
de esta función para sentirnos bien de
lo que acabamos de hacer de esta manera
analítica vamos a verlo por acá déjame
bajar un poco la pantalla y déjame traer
por aquí la gráfica de esta función así
que voy a copiar y pegar y ya está ahora
puedes ver que este valor de aquí es
igual a 1 entre la raíz cuadrada de iu
además puedes ver que en efecto tenemos
un mínimo yo no era tan obvio verlo así
pero ahora podemos apreciar que este es
un mínimo absoluto y además que no
tenemos un punto máximo absoluto
solamente hay valores que crecen y
crecen y crecen indefinidamente